of course we could uh see this coming
that's why we've uh put the the steps in
place that we we already have and don't
forget that
although there will be more uh
announcements next month more cash
coming uh from september onwards you
shouldn't forget that the the pipeline
of cash uh stretches out uh throughout
the autumn uh so uh there's gonna be
another 650 pounds uh coming for every
uh uh one of the eight million most
vulnerable households in october
in november another 300 pounds to help
every pensioner 150 pounds extra
for everybody who is entitled to
disability benefits on top of what we're
doing with uh universal credit and uh
the living wage lifting both of those up
and so
cash there's a there's a pipeline of
cash coming through over the next few
months and uh through the uh the autumn
and the the winter but that is clearly
now going to be
augmented increased by extra cash that
the government is plainly going to be
announcing in september i want to make a
point about about the what we're doing
we want to target the household so
most of the money will go to the 8
million most vulnerable households
that's the right thing to do a lot of
money will be going to absolutely
everybody but what i don't think we
should be doing is trying to
try to
cap the whole thing for absolutely
everybody the richest households in the
country this will go on for a few months
but and it will go on over the over the
winter and it will be it will be tough
and i've been very clear about that but
in the end we're also putting in the
measures we need to ensure that we have
the energy independence to get through
this and we're putting in more nuclear
we're putting in more wind power we've
already seen a 26 increase in british
gas now from the from the north sea
and uh we're ending our dependence on
putin's hydrocarbons last in june for
the first time in a very very long time
uh we imported no hydrocarbons from
russia so what i'm saying to you is that
the whole world is suffering this energy
spike it's caused by
putin's aggression
in ukraine but and i accept that it's
it's tough for people and we're doing
everything we can to to help and huge
huge sums uh being spent now and and
some more sums uh will be spent in the
months ahead but we're going to get
through this
and in the end we'll come out in a much
stronger position and putin is going to
be in a weaker position and his ability
to impose that economic blackmail will
diminish over time